[Music]
it was reported recently that
the mood around getting a coronavirus
vaccine is becoming more aggressive in
germany
huh who would have guessed that
something aggressive
would happen in germany wait a minute
what day is it may 14th second friday of
the month
oh my god report card day report card
day
yeah ally ship report card day the day
we find out
how well we're doing at being an ally
now
i'm gonna go to my mailbox to see if my
report card is here
howdy amber hi mr mailman happy ally
ship report card day
happy hour ship report card data you too
it congrats by the way tarek congrats
on what he got all a's on his report
card this quarter
well thank you but i don't need
congratulations i'm i'm just doing the
work that we should all be doing to be a
good ally
wowie sally somebody's already gearing
up for
next year here's your card amber i hope
you've been putting in the work to be a
good ally
i sure have as the world gets more
expansive and we start to recognize more
and more people and cultures that have
been historically overlooked
it's not just good to do the work it's
ness's
three season and f what the hell mailman
oh
i guess you haven't been putting in
enough work to make your allyship seem
like it's not just performative
this doesn't make sense there must be
some kind of mistake i mean look
lgbtq ally ship i gotta see
but i have so many queer friends oh
upholding those friendships as proof of
your allyship instead of the
contributions you've made to their
community is a really bad way to be an
ally plus you've been watching a lot of
friends reruns
okay what about this racial ally ship i
gotta see in that too but how
i'm black name one black person
what are you serious no
you're stalling should have been easier
than that
plus you've been watching a lot of
friends reruns shut up tarik you name
one black person
amber ruffin wow zowie the man don't
miss
i think i'm trying a lot more than i'm
getting credit for
like how did i get to see an
international allyship
i mean you did just make a crack about
the troubled history of germany
yeah that was weird it wasn't even part
of the monologue you just did it in the
middle of the show
okay that's fair i guess but an f
in class ally ship no freaking way
i give money to every homeless person i
see on the street
i'm reading constantly about class
solidarity i tip
every essential worker i engage with
during the pandemic
i even walk dogs for a nice older lady
in my building who's lived there since
the great depression
now i might not be a perfect ally but
i'm putting in the work to make sure
that i'm going to be a better one
and isn't that what being a good ally is
all about
hi amber what's my name
what's that now what's my name
mr mailman
you think my name is the job i took to
feed my family
yes well good luck on your report card
next year
congrats again tarik catch you later
catch you later hezekiah
you